[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم اسماعيل هانيه يصف
اغتيال القيادي في حماس صالح العاروري
بالعمل الارهابي ورئيس المساد يقول ان كل
من شارك في هجوم السابع من اكتوبر دمه
مهدور ومسؤولون امريكيون يقولون ان
العمليه ضمن هجمات
تنفذها اسرائيل ضد حماس وايران تقول ان
الاغتيال عمل ارهابي وتشدد على ان اسرائيل
اخلت بتوازن المنطقه تجدون المزيد من
اخبار الحرب على غزه في رابط بالتعليقات
في ذكرى اغتياله تفجيران قرب مرقدي قائد
فيلق القدس السابق قاسم سليماني رئيس
منظمه الطوارئ الايرانيه في كرمان يقول ان
حصيله ضحايا الانفجارين في كرمان ترتفع
الى اكثر من 100 قتيل والرئيس الايراني
يقول ان الانتقال ممن يقفون خلف الهجوم
الارهابي في كرمان حتمي
وقطعي بعد قصف روسي استهدف كياف اوكرانيا
تشن هجمات على شبه جزيره القرم ومنطقتي
روسيتين حدوديت والدفاع الجوي الروسي يعلن
اعتراض سته صواريخ فوق منطقه بلغورد التي
تعرضت لهجوم اوكراني اواخر العام
الماضي القضاء الفرنسي يصدر حكما بالسجن
لمده ثمانيه اشهر مع وقف التنفيذ وغ ماليه
قدرها 45 الف يورو بحق لاعب الكره
الجزائري يوسف عطال بتهمه ما اسمته اثاره
الكراهيه بعد دعمه الشعب الفلسطيني في غزه
ونشره مقطعا زعم ان فيه عبارات معاديه
للساميه الى
اللقاء